oh
[Musique]
qui je suis d'où je viens
mes origines vous voyez très bien où je
vais vous emmener
laissez moi vous dire que je vais vous
raconter une histoire qui n'est pas
encore finie je vais vous raconter mon
voyage vers mon africanité
avant cela je tiens à vous dire que je
m'appelle audrey kamali et que depuis
peu j'ai rajouté ou en bail et le prénom
de ma mère parce que ce sont ces deux
personnes là qui m'ont amené à voyager
je voudrais vous dire aussi que ce soir
j'ambitionne de vous expliquer comment
j'ai compris entre 2018 et 2019 que
j'étais africaine
pour cela nous allons remonter vingt ans
en arrière
j'ai cinq ans en mars 1998 je viens
d'atterrir sur le territoire français et
j'entends ma mère prononcé une phrase
qui résonnera pour toujours dans ma tête
je demande l'asile politique
cette phrase-là a son importance parce
que c'est avec cette phrase là que
j'aimerais vous expliquer pourquoi
j'aime la france
oui je suis ici pour vous dire que je ne
parlerai pas du génocide
je ne parlerai pas non plus de ses
années d'exil je suis ici pour faire une
éloge sur la france j'aime la france
alors parce que ma mère prenant cette
phrase en 1998 j'aime la france
également parce que un an après notre
arrivée cette france-là va réunir toute
ma famille et nous accorder cet asile
politique
j'aime la france aussi parce qu'en 2002
quatre ans après notre arrivée en france
fait exceptionnel pour des africains si
africain exactement nous devenons en
quatre ans français c'est pour ces
raisons là que j'aime la france
la france est un pays qui m'a accueilli
la france est un pays aussi qui m'a
protégé la france
en réalité c'est un pays qui m'a permis
de me reconstruire et qui a permis à ma
famille de se reconstruire se
reconstruire ça n'a pas été évident en
mars 1998
nous sommes accueillis dans ce qu'on
appelle un centre d'accueil pour
demandeurs d'asile
c'est dans ce centre là que je vais
découvrir pour la première fois les
joies de l'enfance
je vais découvrir ses joies là aux côtés
d'autres enfants qui ont un parcours
aussi tortueux que le mien ils viennent
d'ex yougoslavie ils viennent d'afrique
du nord d'afrique subsaharienne ou bien
d'asie et c'est cette france là en
réalité que j'aime c'est une france
terre d'immigration et terre d'accueil
mais en france rien n'est vraiment
simple
c'est vrai nous nous sommes reconstruit
en france mais dans une ville qui
s'appelle béziers croyez-moi ce n'est
pas de gaieté de coeur que ce soir je
vous parle de cette ville
cette villa c'est l'opposé de ma france
à moi terre d'accueil d'immigration
béziers c'est une ville qui a vu au fur
des années son électorat préféré le vote
pour l'extrême droite mais moi je
n'avais pas vraiment le choix
quand vous habitez à béziers dans mon
cas vous avez deux options la première
c'est être acceptée et vous faire
accepter par les français de béziers
la deuxième c'est attendre attendre le
moment vous allez avoir la possibilité
de vous en aller le plus loin possible
pour décider du reste de votre vie
à ce moment là j'ai décidé que je
voulais être acceptée à tout prix à tout
prix je vous le répète j'aime la france
j'aime ce pays et je voulais être
acceptée à tout prix par la france parce
que la france représentait pour moi
l'opposé du continent africain c'est un
pays stable c'est un pays paisible
c'est un pays où il fait bon de vivre
c'était donc pour moi le poser du
continent africain
pour vous dire vrai j'avais de quoi me
faire accepter par les français de
béziers trois arguments pour moi le
premier ma famille et de la bonne
religion diront certains français nous
sommes catholiques
le deuxième mon père est passé de
réfugiés africains a immigré africain
qui exercent un métier plutôt valorisant
il était professeur de mathématiques au
collège et au lycée
le troisième j'aurais préféré que mes
parents me donne un prénom africains
mais ils ont préféré m'appeler audrey
audrey c'est très facile d'être acceptée
a baisé quand vous vous appelez audrey
sans doute que pour moi ça aurait été
encore plus compliqué si par exemple je
m'étais appelé fatoumata je trouve que
c'est un très beau prénom mais souvent
la plupart des biterrois parce qu'il
s'appelle comme ça bien sûr trouve que
ce n'est pas du tout un bon prix n'ont
donc je voulais être acceptée par la
france ce que j'essaie de vous expliquer
c'est qu'en réalité
peut-être que la france était un pays
par défaut peut-être j'avais quitté le
rwanda à l'âge d'un an
en réalité je pense que ce pays n'avait
pas vraiment été le mien
qu'on soit bien clair je connaissais
très bien d'où je venais j'avais la
chance de grandir dans une famille où
l'on parlait le kinyarwanda de grandir
dans une famille qui avait un
attachement profond pour la culture
rodez mais avoir un petit souci au son
c'est que dans cette famille là même si
les ethnies n'existent n'existe plus
comme telle de nos jours au rwanda
je grandissais avec un père où tout est
avec une maman d'outils
c'est très délicat l'art amour leur
avait permis de se mettre ensemble ils
s'étaient battus pour se mettre ensemble
mais leur amour les avait aussi fait
fuir ce pays
mon père était un haut placé au rwanda
ma mère était une femme tutsie qui
n'avait jamais eu la possibilité de
décider pour elles-mêmes déplacer à deux
ans obligés d'aller apprendre à coudre
et à cuisiner à 10 ans elle s'est battu
battu pour aider sa famille je vous
parle d'une dame qui n'a pas fait
beaucoup d'études mais qui s'est
retrouvée secrétaire paul minn
pour le maire de kigali je vous parle
d'une dame qui me disait que dans sa
jeunesse elle savait que réussir sa vie
c'était épouser un ou tous et je ne
voulais pas rue réveiller les blessures
familiales à la maison en parlant du
rwanda donc je préférais la france et
j'étais avant le tout et surtout
françaises surtout français il fut un
temps
heureusement j'ai pu commencer à décider
de ma vie j'ai commencé lorsque j'ai eu
mon bac en prenant mes valises et en
installant à montpellier une grande
ville juste à côté
là bas j'ai décidé de commencer des
études en droit suffit toujours faut
croire que j'ai envie de justice pendant
ses études en droit
je ne pensais qu'à une chose voyager
voyager
après tout j'avais un passeport français
et pour moi ce passeport français
représentait la liberté j'ai donc décidé
à la fin de mes études de droit
nos diplômes en poche bien sûr de m'en
aller très loin
prendre une année sabbatique je me suis
rendu je me suis rendu pardon dans un
pays bien différent de la france est
dans un pays qui n'était pas en afrique
je suis parti pour l'inde là bas j'y ai
vécu ce que j'appelle le réveil indien
j'ai vécu un réveil vis-à-vis de mon
identité culturelle en inde
j'étais basées à bengalore à bangalore
j'habitais avec une famille indienne et
je travaillais pour une ong locale qui
luttaient pour la scolarisation des
enfants
ça peut sembler très altruiste de ma
part je peux vous donner l'impression
d'avoir fait beaucoup de choses mais en
réalité je ne faisais strictement rien
dans cet hommage et pour la simple et
bonne raison que je ne parlais pas la
langue locale allait essayer de donner
des cours d'anglais à des enfants
traumatisés par les violences familiales
qui sont vécues
quand vous ne pouvez pas vous faire
comprendre par eux ni en français ni en
anglais rendez vous dans un bidonville à
bangalore pour essayer de sensibiliser
ces familles contre les violences
domestiques
quand vous ne parlez pas quand vous ne
parlez que anglais et français
ces familles là vous regarde roche la
tête et vous font comprendre qu'elles
n'ont strictement rien à faire
ce n'est pas grave linguistiquement en
inde je n'ai rien appris rien du tout à
part peut-être bouger la tête comme ça
pour dire oui mais l'inde je voulais dit
c'est un réveil c'est là bas que j'ai
commencé à entamer cette transformation
à l'intérieur du court grâce à deux
éléments
le premier élément c'est que là bas je
vais nouer des amitiés très forte avec
des personnes extraordinaires mais des
personnes aussi qui vont me permettre
d'avoir une toute autre compréhension du
monde
ces personnes là vont ouvrir des yeux
sur le monde je vais essayer d'expliquer
que quelque chose d'assez compliqué pour
vous puisque on est très loin de nantes
l'inde c'est un continent il y à 1,3
milliard d'habitants en inde l'inde
c'est un continent où l'on parle
couramment 120 langues
maintenant j'habitais à bangalore à
wingles alors on se trouve dans l'état
du karnataka dans cet état là on parle
une langue locale le canada cas à l as
des as pas le pays
c'est un habitant du karnataka qui ne
parlent que le canada se rendre dans
l'état voisin le tamil nadu où l'on
parle le tamoul si cette habitante qui
ne parlent que le canada ne parle donc
ni l'anglais ni lindy et de langues
nationales
croyez-moi il pourra essayer autant de
fois qu'il veut de rentrer en
communication avec un habitant du tamil
nadu qui ne parlent que le tamoul ils ne
resteront pas se comprendre
est ce que je venais de comprendre là
c'était qu'il était tout à fait possible
se sentir un peu étranger dans son
propre pays
et cette première compréhension du monde
que je venais de comprendre vous pouvez
vivre dans votre propre pays de
naissance et vous sentir appartenir à
une communauté culturelle bien
identifiés la deuxième raison qui a
provoqué cette transformation
c'est que là bas je vais rencontrer
beaucoup d'indiens les indiens voyage
énormément
beaucoup d'entre eux ont eu à séjourner
en afrique très content de voir il m'a
proches par curiosité il me demande d'où
je viens est ce que je viens de gander
des tubes pied de tanzanie j'en passe
à chaque fois je leur réponds un très
fier non je suis française et j'étais
surprise de les voir surprise par ma
réponse à l'est pendant un long moment
défendre votre nationalité française
vous allez comprendre qu'en réalité une
partie de vous et incomplètes
une partie de moi étaient incomplètes et
je le comprenais enfin ma famille avait
tout fait tout fait pour transmettre la
culture et la langue rwandaise
mais je n'avais pas grandi là bas donc
elle avait beau essayer je n'avais que
des bribes comme je n'avais que des
bribes et que je passais mon temps à
brandir cette nationalité
je me suis dit prenons un avion alors à
kigali alors voir à quoi ressemble le
rwanda avril 2015 pour la première fois
je retourne au rwanda mais je retourne
aussi en afrique pour la première là bas
je vais y vivre une succession de chocs
le premier choc il est très brève brutal
mais très brève
c'est un choc olfactif pour toutes les
personnes qui sont ici vous êtes en
afrique j'espère qu'une grande majorité
d'entre vous ont eu l'occasion de
quitter ce continent pas le burkina ce
continent parce que ce que je m'apprête
à dire est valable pour tout le
continent vous grandissez ou bien vous
vivez ici une longue période de votre
vie vous quittez ce continent à la
minute où vous descendez de l'avion à
votre tour vous êtes frappés par un choc
olfactif vous redécouvrez la douce odeur
de l'afrique
j'allais quitter l'europe l'afrique
pardon à cinq ans 17 ans plus
mais j'ai réalisé que ma mémoire avait
clairement bien mémorisé sato dollars
faire ressortir le deuxième choc
il est beaucoup plus parce mais ce choc
là c'est un choc d'identité j'avais
grandi dans un pays où personne me
ressembler à béziers à l'époque quand
nous sommes arrivés que nous étions la
seule famille de noirs dans cette ville
donc il n'y avait que des blancs autour
de moi là à kigali
je sortais la première chose que je
voyais des noirs avec un froid aussi
énorme que le mien en plus de voir que
des noirs de partout c'est noir la
parler kinyarwanda et je les comprenais
en hand 120 langues
je ne comprenait aucun indien au burkina
60 langues à peu près je pense je
rencontre ont aucune
donc j'étais dans un pays où les gens me
ressembler et je pouvais communiquer
avec eux j'étais en train de comprendre
que je ressemblais naturellement et que
j'appartenais naturellement à ce pays
c'était chez moi à béziers j'avais lutté
pour être acceptée à kigali
je n'avais même pas besoin de justifier
que j'étais rendait puisque j'étais
rodez le troisième choc il ya plus
personnel très intense
21 ans après avoir quitté ce pays
j'avais passé tout mon temps en temps
parler de gens que je ne connaissais pas
de vue je les avais eu parfois au
téléphone mais je les avais je ne les
avais jamais
c'est donc une famille que j'ai retrouvé
des cousins des oncles des tantes des
personnes avec qui j'aurais aimé grandir
mais ce n'était pas possible
parmi toutes ces personnes il ya une
personne que j'étais vraiment très
heureuse de retrouver
j'avais attendu 17 ans la revoir
c'était ma grand mère paternelle quand
vous ne remplissez pas chez vous il ya
une chose qui vous manquent enfants et
vous le savez très bien
c'est vos grands parents peu importe où
vous grandissez que ce soit sur ce
continent où c'est un autre des
continents vous avez tous des souvenirs
avec vos grands-parents où je vous
souhaite d'avoir des souvenirs avec vos
grands parents
moi je n'en avais pas j'avais perdu mes
deux grands pères avant ma naissance
j'avais perdu ma grand mère maternelle
en 84 ans et j'avais perdu ma grand mère
paternelle en mars 98 le jour nous avons
pris cet avion
elle n'a jamais pu nous rejoindre et
sincèrement je suis contente qu'elle ait
fini sa vie non pas en france mais sur
sa terre natale et je peux vous dire
aussi une chose c'est en la retrouvant
que j'ai compris que c'est aussi le lien
inter générationnel qui fait que l'on se
sent chez soi je vous ai raconté tout ça
mais n'oubliez pas je suis ici parce
qu'on se pose une question et que je me
pose une question c'est quoi connaître
ses origines
je peux vous dire ce que n'est pas
connaître ses origines
quand vous citez juste vos origines vous
ne les connaissez pas je peux vous dire
que connaître ses origines c'est avoir
un héritage culturel que vous n'allez
pas brandir que vous n'allez pas
justifié que vous n'allez jamais
revendiqué connaître vos origines c'est
avoir le droit d'être je peux aussi vous
dire qu'à partir de cette réflexion
avoir le droit d'être quand je suis
sorti de cette année sabbatique
j'ai pris le temps j'ai décidé de
changer mon cursus universitaire je suis
passé de droit à sociologie et
développement par montpellier pas en
france mais en belgique
pourquoi je me pose encore la question
j'adore la belgique où je ne comprends
toujours pas pourquoi je suis resté là
bas est tombée amoureuse de ce pays
ce que je sais par contre c'est qu'en
belgique l'ancien pays colonisateur du
monde à c'est là on trouve la plus dense
communauté rodez ce que je sais
également c'est que la belgique c'est un
pays frontaliers de la france c'est
aussi là où on trouve la prudence
communauté française donc je peux vous
dire que connaître ses origines
ce ne pas avoir à choisir dans mon cas
je n'avais pas à choisir quand j'étais
en belgique entre la communauté
française et la communauté rodez parce
que j'étais en train de comprendre que
c'était juste savoir d'où je viens et
qui je suis non affirmé mon appartenance
à une communauté quelle qu'elle soit
c'est la première partie de cette
définition
la deuxième partie de ma définition
c'est que je venais de comprendre aussi
que connaître ses origines c'est avoir
le devoir d'être aujourd'hui je ne
revendique pas mes origines comme une
fierté
je ne revendique pas non plus ma
nationalité comme un privilège j'ai
appris par contre que c'était des
parties fortes et complémentaires de mon
identité
à l'heure actuelle aujourd'hui je suis
très heureuse d'avoir grandi en france
parce que j'ai appris à prendre le
meilleur de ce que la france pouvait me
donner à l'heure actuelle je suis
également très heureuse de vous dire que
je suis et que je resterai pour toujours
rodez à l'heure actuelle aussi j'habite
au burkina faso c'est un très beau pays
là aussi me demandez pas pourquoi je
suis venu ici je me pose encore la
question
au burkina faso c'est ici que j'ai
consolidé cette pensée au burkina faso
c'est une ancienne colonie française
très souvent il m'arrive de tomber sur
des jeunes et des moins jeunes qui voue
une adoration que j'avoue ne pas
comprendre pour la france
si j'avais un seul et unique message à
transmettre à ces personnes là c'est que
je pense sincèrement que la france ne
résout rien du tout la france ne sera
jamais une solution
jamais je peux même vous dire que la
france sur un problème si vous ne
comprenez pas la force de ce droit et de
ce devoir d'être aujourd'hui j'ai envie
de vous dire que vous avez le droit
d'être burkinabè mais que vous avez le
devoir aussi de défendre ce droit
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous dire que
je vous explique cela par ce que j'ai
appris à aimer mon africanité
mais j'ai aussi appris à les harmoniser
avec mon histoire bien française
aujourd'hui je me suis envie de dire que
ce voyage n'est pas fini loin de là
c'est sans doute le voyage de toute une
vie
mais j'aurai un dernier message à vous
faire passer que vous soyez afrique en
afrique ou africains d'ailleurs vous
avez le devoir de chercher à connaître
vos origines
vous avez aussi le devoir de ne jamais
envier ceux qui viennent d'ailleurs
parce que malheureusement nous sommes à
une époque où l'afrique est à la mode
c'est vrai mais les africains ne le sont
toujours pas je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]